Nancy Pelosi who is by my last count 584
years old she is running for re-election
Nancy tweeted Out quote now more than
ever our city needs us to advance San
Francisco values and further our country
yeah yeah we we need drug addled bums
defecating on the street from Sea to
shining sea that's what we need we need
two cars in every garage and a syringe
in every pot that we need San Francisco
values in America uh our country needs
America to show the world that our flag
is still there it's a rainbow flag by
the way it's not the red white and blue
they got rid of that one but the rainbow
flag is still there with liberty and
justice for all that's why I'm running
for reelection and respectfully ask for
your vote Nancy and now look especially
depending on what happens in 2024 it's
going to be very dangerous for Nancy
Pelosi to be in office because she
remembers the compromise of 1877 so
she's going to be able to wield power
very effectively uh I don't I don't mind
that she's running for re-election it's
not good it's bad but kind of get a kick
out of some of these Old-Timers who have
been these women of a certain age and
some of the old-timer male politicians
who have been around forever Bernie you
know all of them they're going to hold
on as long as they can the people are
allowing them to hold on okay that's
just how politics Works however I will
say the longer the geriatric politicians
hang on the more massive the political
sea change is going to be once they
inevitably have to leave office because
the old Grim re finally shows
up it that's just a fact they can hold
on in both parties Nancy Pelosi can hold
on Mitch McConnell can hold on Joe Biden
can hold on they can they can hold
on we we had what a we had a boomer
president in Bill Clinton Boomer
president in George
Bush I thought a boomer I thought a Gen
X president in Barack Obama some gen
xers have written into me screaming and
said Michael how dare you associate him
with us
Obama is technically a boomer okay so
fine kamam is a boomer then another
Boomer president with Donald Trump it's
four Boomer presidents and then Joe
Biden who's the silent generation who
was before the Baby Boomers so these
guys have held on to power for an
extraordinarily long period of time and
all that means is that the Next
Generation that comes up is going to be
that much more removed is going to
differ that much more from the views of
that previous generation there's no
there's no stopping change forever it
will have to happen time rolls on
History rolls on you look right now at
Hungary a government that a lot of
American conservatives quite admire
because it's the only country that's
been able to turn around its birth rate
problem the only country that's been
able to stop Mass migration the only
country that's been able to to rebuy its
cities it's the only it's the only
country where the cities are getting
more beautiful not uglier and part of
the reason they've been able to do that
is the government is quite young in
Hungary it's a vibrant young government
that's not just stuck with the old
platitudes of the 1980s but is is think
applying Eternal principles to to the
new circumstances that confront us um
that's going to happen here eventually
it's going to have to when that grip of
power runs out and this is why I would
encourage conservatives not just to
recite the same platitudes that you
learned in 1982 platitudes which may or
may not have even been true
then you know politics often boils down
to talking points and talking points are
always wrong because they are always
over simp
they never tell the whole story
sometimes they outright lie if we just
keep rehearsing the same old script that
we learned in 1982 we're going to keep
on losing just like we have since 1982
almost without exception or we can use
our imagination we can dig into history
we can dig into philosophy and we can
and we can imagine we can think about
what the future looks like and bring
that to effect right now go to
expressvpn.com going online with that
expressvpn is like leaving your kids
with the nearest stranger while using
the restroom would you ever do that I
should hope not most of the time though
you'd say it's probably fine but you
never truly know who it is you're
trusting so why would you risk it that's
why you need to be using expressvpn
every time you connect to an unencrypted
Network cafes hotels airports pretty
much any network that's not your own
your online data are not secured any
hacker on the same network can gain
access to and steal your personal data
your passwords your financial details
you name it expressvpn creates a secure
encrypted tunnel between your device and
the internet so that hackers can't steal
your data hackers can make some serious
cash selling personal info on the dark
web however expressvpn has made it
easier than ever to keep your
information safe just fire up the app
click one button you are instantly
protected works on all your devices
laptops phones tablets so easy that even
I can use it go to expressvpn.com get
three extra months for free
expressvpn.com
to learn more right now go to hall. /ns
there is no better time to build a daily
habit of prayer and meditation building
a habit of prayer can help you cultivate
an attitude of gratitude focusing on
what you are thankful for can increase
positive emotions and improve overall
well-being also you owe prayer to the
Lord your God so you need to pray hallo
is the number one Christian Prayer app
in the United States it has helped
countless people maintain a daily prayer
routine and it can help you too download
the app for free at hall.com
Nolls you can set prayer reminders and
track your progress all along the way
not sure where to start check out father
Mike schmitz's Bible any Year my
favorite podcast available on the hallo
app for brief daily readings and
Reflections or pray alongside Mark
Wahlberg Jim cisel and even some
worldclass athletes with hallow you can
customize a personal prayer plan that
works for you listen wherever you are
with downloadable offline sessions using
hallow to connect with others who share
your beliefs and values can provide a
sense of belonging support and Foster a
sense of community and you will learn to
be a better person in today's broken
world right now go to hall.com try three
months for free hall.com
speaking of geriatric politicians Joe
Biden is slumping among non-white voters
which is a big problem because the
Democrats rely on a total lock on racial
minorities so if they lose the racial
minorities especially black voters uh
they they could lose basically every
election this is according to CNN and
SSRS shows Trump is up one over
Biden um so for the people who say Trump
can't win you know again that was
disproved by history because Trump did
win in 2016 and maybe who knows who
knows what happened in 2020 uh Biden is
hitting his targets among whites so
Biden is matching 43 44% of decided maor
major party white voters that he won
last time but he's he's losing in some
nonwhite support meaning that he's not
he's not behind on non-white voters he's
still massively ahead on non-white
voters he's just not as far ahead as he
was last time so Joe Biden still wins
58- 34 among non-white voters according
to Nate con of the New York Times but
because he's lost some ground this could
could be a big problem for him uh Trump
for instance got 29% of the Hispanic
vote uh in
2016 that was compared to Romney's 27%
of the vote so this is very funny that
Trump who called Mexicans rapists and
murderers was able to do better among
Hispanics than milk toast nice nice
sounding Mitt Romney and really upended
a lot of the chattering classes you know
establishments uh anti-trump rhetoric in
2016 but still 29 versus 27 it's not
it's not a lot it's it's fine and and
Trump does better among non-white voters
than most Republicans he got 8% of the
black vote compared to 6% that Mitt
Romney got okay that's fine but this
also highlights the political importance
of immigration for whatever reason
Republicans just don't do that well with
non-white voters that is why the
Democrats are flooding the country with
illegal aliens because they are by and
large almost entirely non-white
immigrants and they're not doing it
because they care about the Venezuelans
or the Hondurans the poor people
crossing the border paying off the
cartels to be smuggled and raped and
trafficked and and sometimes killed
along the way they're just doing it
because it swells their numbers and it
swells their numbers in a whole L of
ways it swells their numbers in Congress
because Congressional apportionment the
number of districts that that a state
will get is based on total population
not based on citizens so you flood the
country with illegal aliens millions and
millions of year that's going to
increase especially in Democrat places
at California it's going to increase
their representation it's going to
increase their their representation in
the Electoral College it's going to
increase their proportion of the voters
it's got It's it's helping them this is
not something where we can say Well in
30 years hopefully will just pass a law
and you know the Hispanics are
conservatives they just don't know it
yet some of them are and it actually
varies by nationality Cubans tend to be
much more Republican than say voters
from I don't know
uh Venezuela say or Guatemala um and the
children of these immigrants and the
grandchildren of these immigrants but by
and large they're still
anti-conservative they still go for the
Democrats this is an emergency because
well we can be chattering about the
precise application of the rule of the
law and whether title 42 is acceptable
or not should we really arrest these
poor people fleeing the persecution of
what they're they're seeking persecution
by signing up with the cartels while
we're while we're debating that the
country is being radically transformed
as an intentional program by the
Democrats to swell their numbers and to
to make the Republicans a permanent
minority forget about racial minorities
cultural minorities religious minorities
it just as an electoral matter that's
what the Democrats are after here we
just going to let that happen or are we
going to are we going to get creative in
how to enforce the law at the very least
the highest sense of the law in spirit
boy what a great clip that was now make
sure that you ring that Bell subscribe
to the Michael NS podcast we'll see you
next time